ladies and gentlemen
welcome to wild ride with stevo
this one is a good one we got a
king of comedy a guy who i relate to
very
intimately and uh what else can i say
man
i'm really excited about this one so
ladies and gentlemen jeff dunham yeah
dude
thanks for having me ah dude thanks for
for joining us this is my co-host scott
randolph how you doing hey scott
how's it going good and wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait what's the one
little
rectangular tat you've seen one little
tiny red this one
yeah what's that it's a
it's like a it's a blue square with a
wave in the middle
is it what does it mean anything no i
don't have any tattoos that means
anything right show me your pot leaf
i'm a pot leaf i got a pot leaf he went
to go get a palm tree and it just looks
like a pot leaf
yeah nice what else do i got
well we'll talk about that they're
they're all pretty bad
not my dog pretty bad yeah
my dog wendy's sitting here i think she
knew that we were gonna have you
and she wanted to look like a puppet
that's steve's
dog normally she uh lays down
wendy lay down so stevo i missed the
news the past few days so
could you i know all your viewers and
listeners must know but
so duct tape to the to the billboard is
that what it was
it was that one uh it's it was in august
so it's been a couple it's been longer
it's been a couple months
but i had this really really provocative
crazy uh adults-only
multimedia comedy special called gnarly
which i distributed direct to consumers
streaming from my website stevo.com and
i wanted to promote that so i bought a
billboard duct tape myself to it
got all kinds of great press but you
know what dude it's such a great
entry point to talk to you because of
course jeff
dunham the the not only the world's
most famous ventriloquist but
probably the only famous ventriloquist
yeah there's a good reason for that
right but now one night small union
one one night i was holed up in a
hotel room on tour somewhere and uh
it's not even usual for me to watch tv
but i turned on the tv
and and just sat there and watched an
entire
hour-long documentary about you
and well yeah dude it was fascinating
and i
i related so intimately to your struggle
with trying to sell comedy specials if i
remember right from the documentary
i think you taped your own comedy
special but nobody would buy it
is that right yeah what happened was it
was back this was back in 0.5 i guess
and i
i was in the comedy club world and i was
at the top of the food chain in that
but i couldn't get any higher was the
glass ceiling you know nobody would take
me seriously beyond that selling out
clubs all over the country but no
television so nobody
who wanted to be the executive that
failed with the show about the
ventriloquist
you know what i mean nobody wanted to be
that guy
so nobody would give me a special
nothing i'd get on you know eating at
the improv and all those things
so um my management at the time did one
of those deals and they said look
uh if jeff films a special will you uh
i'm sorry this was after i'd filmed
i filmed it and uh i i paid for it
myself and back then that was a lot of
money i think i spent 150 grand it was
it was a lot of cash and the special was
great but nobody
nobody wanted it so my management went
to comedy central and they said
look we'll give you this guy will you
please put him on
and we'll give you this other guy that's
more famous as well so it was one of
those kind of deals
so comedy central said okay uh we'll
take dunham we'll play it one time
and that's it and stopped bothering us
and they said fine
so it aired on a friday night and then
on monday we called him for the ratings
and they said
um uh we think there's been some kind of
mistake
we'll get back to you but you know doing
comedy clubs for 20 years
i built that grassroot following all
over the place so when people tuned in
it was like the numbers were off the
charts and they couldn't get the second
one fast enough so
that was that was that was a cool time
in life man that's great
you know like in my case it's not that
uh
that i i bring props or anything but i i
was fighting uphill like you said
doing very well on the comedy circuit
but couldn't get anywhere else
and uh i think that there's sort of a
built-in resistance to
the jackass guy as a stand-up comedian
you know
and where i thought i cracked the code
was you know i got my first special
you know it came and went with like very
mediocre
viewership and as i put together my
subsequent
hour one night performing on stage it
just struck me
oh my god all of these salacious crazy
true stories i'm telling like for the
most part
happened on camera so i can keep
developing this
act and then in post-production
actually edit the footage of said
stories
into it so that it's a fully multimedia
presentation we've never seen that
before you know like
the the the comedian standing there
holding the mic
except the stuff i'm talking about is
edited in now she's like wow
so i just immediately set out to start
recording my performances
putting it all in the computer editing
it together it worked fantastically well
and i was absolutely completely
just convinced that this was gonna be
where i cracked the code
and then everybody had to recognize me
and they're gonna and i funded the
special
because of the multimedia and i went and
filmed all these extra things to like
have vignettes
with all of the vignettes i spent more
like three hundred thousand dollars on
it
and nobody would buy it and i was in
that position with this special that is
my baby and i loved it so great it's the
one called gnarly which i duct taped
myself to the billboard for
right nobody would buy it and here i was
uh
watching your documentary and it said uh
you know you had the special nobody
would buy it
and i was like that's me i wear kindred
spirits
you know but uh i almost think that
it um turned out to be a blessing rather
than a curse that nobody would buy it
because what i did was uh
you know built a player into my website
with uh you know
streaming it right there with my own
little paywall and i got my money back i
even made some money on it so wow that's
great
and i own it forever so yeah yeah the
world is so different right now it's
almost like you don't need anybody
anymore it's
you know because so like my special's
coming up on uh for on friday
after thanksgiving and uh
and i think we can go ahead and call
that tomorrow
because this will come out on uh on
thanksgiving day so as people are just
watching this freshly it's coming out
tomorrow and if
and if if today's the day after
thanksgiving then tune in
right now where are they watching it
eight o'clock
comedy central eastern end pacific and
then the middle time zones mountain and
central it screws me up i don't know how
it works you know you know what i
by the way when i moved to los angeles i
grew up in the central time zone so i
moved to los angeles
where'd you grow up i grew up in five
different countries
oh oh my god never mind he's a triple
national
yeah never mind but when i moved out to
california it's like
what do you mean football comes on at 10
a.m that's not right
but no wonder nobody goes to church out
here it's so funny that when i moved to
california i was furious that the bar is
closed at 2 a.m
it's totally different but it's still
the same
what what part of the central time zone
did you grow up i was in dallas
yeah yeah so yeah i lived there for many
years and then came out here and that
was it you've been
very faithful to comedy central am i
correct you've you've had
previously six comedy specials i i slept
around
after a little while so i was with them
if you say six then i'll believe you
that sounds about right
and then for a little while i left them
and did one on nbc and then two on
netflix but now we're back to comedy
central and i you know i have
of their the top four specials on
the highest ratings ever i have the
three of those so
it's really nice to come back and uh
yeah it's it's it's great
but it's one of the it's one of three so
apparently if this one goes well uh
there's going to be two more after this
but you know here's the weird part i
don't know if this was in the press
release or whatever it was
but and this is true not one of these
jokes had i
ever told to any other human being on
the planet before i walked on stage that
night and taped the special
because yeah usually what i would do is
spend 18 or 24 months
building the show joke by joking bit by
bit you know you build it on the road
yeah you make what works you do it over
and over again
and uh just make sure you got it down
this time like everybody i'm sitting
around
and i don't know how the road warriors
have done it the guys that have been on
the road forever like rock bands and the
crews and all that
what are the stories that are going to
come out what are these guys doing with
their time
yeah are you making reference to the
pandemic
huh yeah okay and i was sitting around
going what the hell am i going to do and
then i thought
i saw a couple other guys come out with
specials and i thought you know what i
can do this too
so uh got together with a handful of my
writer friends and we wrote uh all the
stuff and then for two weeks i sat in my
office for five and six hours a day
just cobbling this stuff together
putting the right jokes for the right
characters rewriting and putting it all
together all on the computer didn't
practice it for anybody
didn't say it didn't even tell a joke to
my wife none of my friends
and walked on stage that and i thought i
don't know if this is going to work so
basically what i did was i talked comedy
central into buying an open mic night
nice that's great so when was this taped
uh three weeks ago holy crap
what did the audience look like i'll
tell you if that audience looked
anything like i do right now then
it looked sweet because i'm feeling fit
and frankly jacked why because i'm
training smart man i know
when to train how well i got my whoop
app
tells me like for example today is a
green day it's go
time baby and so i'm gonna be working
out like
crazy you know the last time i went
surfing
it just automatically knew like
you went surfing it's because my whoop
band
i wear it on my right wrist this thing
is the most badass
fitness tracker in the world connects to
the app
knows exactly how much i slept
like how much i recovered what my
activities were
how much i'm ready to train in the
morning and speaking of training i'm
getting ready to go on a
big old badass bike ride from los
angeles all the way to san diego and
down the coast mind you it's going to be
way over 100 miles and i'm ready you
know why because i'm training smart
and i'm training good yeah thanks to my
woop app and i want you to try it so
you're going to go to woop.com w-h-o
dot-com you sign up and when you check
out use the promo code stevo you get 15
off
again that's 15 off at checkout when you
use the promo code stevo
at whoop.com really
it's making me fitter more rested
happier and healthier and i want the
same for you so try it out now let's
talk about this audience
oh it was great we we did it in malibu
and this is how stupid i am i've been
living here for 30 years
and i i'm 15 miles away from malibu i
always thought malibu was like the beach
and that was it i had no idea that there
was like canyons and mountains in malibu
because somebody said we found a good
venue in malibu i'm like oh that's great
we'll have the beach behind us
we see some waves that would be nice
it was in the mountains in the canyon it
was at a winery and uh it was great
calamigo's ranch oh okay oh i was at the
place
that was a giraffe that makes everybody
mad no no no no
no no no no no actually i i
it's not uh calamigos ranch i just shot
there for something super top secret
yeah pretty much pretty recently yeah
yeah it had a uh it had a huge ferris
wheel
was there a ferris wheel there man we're
talking about two different places
giraffes and ferris wheels right okay
it's george clooney's
tequila
so it was um it was a hundred people uh
and
everybody properly socially distanced
never had on masks and
and uh you know what's funny is comedy
central didn't want to talk about it
didn't want to
put press to this thing until after two
weeks it passed to make sure that we
weren't a super spreader
but then i'm like well what if we had
been a super spreader would you
just trash the special and like never
shown it i don't i didn't understand
what the point was but
it's a good question apparently we did
everything you're right and nobody died
so
there you go so when you're i'm paul by
the way i'm off camera jeff nice to meet
you i forgot to introduce paul
no worries but going into this show
i would assume it was a totally
different feeling because normally it's
like you toured it you're confident in
these jokes was it was it a different
feeling walking on stage for this show
where no one had heard these jokes yet
well you know my normal audiences are
you know this is the arenas it's like
between
six and ten thousand so uh this was
should have been somewhat of a shock but
i've been sitting around for months
you know doing jokes for my
five-year-old twin boys
and the dog so to walk on stage after
eight months
having not been anywhere and then you
got 100 people ready to see you
it wasn't as much of a shock as i
thought it would be had i gone one night
from you know a bunch of people in an
arena to this
then that would have been shocking but i
it was just kind of a relief as a
performer it's like you gotta
you know you gotta have the drug and so
you know
and i wasn't really worried about it
because you know
as comics you you you build those bits
from timing you can from just timing and
presentation you
you do the thing enough times you can
start getting laughs where you never
thought there'd be last before because
you think a new stuff and just add a
joke here and a line there this i wasn't
as worried about because it was just
joke joke joke
joke joke joke all related jokes a
routine that was kind of built
was it wasn't like you know there were
there were none of the nuances that
would have happened had this ad
had this been you know performed 100
times so
so i know i wasn't scared it was like
either this is going to work or it's not
going to work but
you know audiences like that they have
to jump through fiery hoops to get there
meaning they really want to be there
they had to go through testing they had
the thing shoved up their face
three days before uh so they're they're
ready to laugh
you know cool and i'm curious also your
preparation
like because you're there's a skill set
involved too which is the ventriloquism
like how much is spent on
mastering the ventriloquism and how much
is spent on like the
the comedy well and ventriloquist
wise it's kind of like learning to play
a sport or an instrument once you got it
you got the basics down and it's not
that big deal
so i'm just on stage talking and moving
a dummy that's about it nice so
yeah there wasn't really you know i
maybe i was a little out of practice on
the not moving the lips kind of thing
but
uh you know otherwise it's it's like
it is just like riding a bike what's the
dog's name again it's wendy
wendy why windy um you know it's the
first name that popped into my mind when
i found her
in the streets of peru what the hell
the streets of peru and how do you get a
dog from peru to here i guess it's not a
big deal
uh it wasn't a big deal for me because i
was shooting a television series down
there and the production took care of
all of the
jumping through hoops and red tape and
all i had to do was pick her up at the
airport
that's pretty great ah dude this dog
goes with me everywhere man
so is this a tour bus what are you on
right now uh it's an rv
it's um it's an rv i use it as my movie
trailer uh the adventures
of my surf hobby and and weekend camping
trips
and it's our podcast studio and soon to
be a mobile tattoo shop
because that's nice so an rv meaning
it's it's got the engine it's not a
trailer
correct correct it is built on a dodge
promaster
uh and it's got got a bathroom it's got
a shower
that's a toilet and a shower wet bath we
just bought an airstream
and drove it up to montana to visit my
uh
one of my daughters so that was that was
an experience what's funny nowadays is
you know you see people all over the
highways now that are complete amateurs
and don't know how to pull a trailer
they're flipping them over all the time
you know that right
oh dude that's great man i
had a smaller van and i was trying to do
uh
this thing with skateboard ramps so i
rented a trailer
i could not reverse with the trailer to
save my life like is that something that
you ever figure out
right yeah that's yeah that's the hard
part no we pulled into this one
campground
and it was like you know you want to
pull through you don't want to have to
back it in and we pulled into this place
in the evening the sun was going down
and of course everybody there is a
complete you know everybody's
well seasoned it's all old guys they
know what's going on
and here i come i hardly ever haven't
backed up a trailer in my life
and this thing's 33 feet long and i'm
like oh my god what am i gonna do
and and it's a and it's not a pull
through i gotta back it in
and my i said to my wife just get out
you know how to do this just
you know point which direction if i
start going the wrong way
and it was one of those where god was
having a boring day and he said i'm
gonna help this
to help this chuckle head out i mean i
pulled it in one shot
perfect and i got i got out and the guy
goes
wow that was nice dude i'm like thanks
man yeah not hard
it was a total lucky shot wow oh my god
i was that i was the worst with it
i'm horrible we have a street my street
here we live at the end of the
cul-de-sac
and there's no way in hell that that you
can drive that trailer down here and
turn around
so i had to back it a quarter mile down
down a whiny street it took an hour to
go a quarter of a mile because i get you
good
yeah i look like an idiot what what made
you want to get the airstream
was it that when you're on your arena
tour
you're living on a tour bus and you just
fall in love with that mobile home
kind of a setup yeah well the tour bus
lives in pennsylvania i don't know why
it just does and so for the family
though we needed
you know something that that i could do
because i i've driven i've driven my own
bus before
i actually stole my own tour bus once
and look i got nothing on you
i can't tell any stories that you'll be
impressed with but there was one day uh
uh one morning
that we had um yeah it was one morning
on a sunday morning
my you know i crew and everybody
everybody's asleep
and i get up and there's my tour bus
sitting at the arena
and i'm like you know i wake up in the
morning and i'm like there's nobody
around here and it's
we were i don't know where we were
somewhere in the southeast it was a
sunday morning nobody was on the streets
and i'm like
i'm going to drive this thing
so i i'd watch my driver dana i'm
watching i've watched him a few times so
i knew how to start it up and i thought
i don't know what the hell i'm doing but
i'm going to drive this damn thing
around so
i got one of my buddies with me and he
started the camera and we did a facebook
live
and i started this thing up and just
started driving around town
and i kept bottoming out every time we
go over here to a slight a slight bump
like yeah i'm like what the hell there's
got to be a button around here because i
knew i was low riding it
i didn't you know i should have used the
uh the airbags or something to pick it
up
but we drove around town i kept
bottoming the damn thing out tearing up
the street
and um uh we went to starbucks so
and my bus driver told me later that his
phone started to explode he said
all kinds of people started calling him
and saying jeff has stolen your tour bus
and he goes no it's his tour bus he can
he can crash it if you want one wow okay
anyway
yeah i can't impress you dude so never
mind i love that
and you you had me at arena
like the uh the whole idea
now we spoke to a comedian who does an
arena tour
or you know the gabriela glaciers he
talks about
every single show is the full catwalk
the whole like you know he says you
can't
go into arena and just stand there with
the microphone you got to bring him that
whole experience and
and uh like he had semi trucks he was
talking about
how many semi trucks does it take to put
on a jeff dunham show at an arena
uh i'm not that i'm not into effects and
that kind of stuff we have a giant a
50-foot uh video wall
that's over my head um and then an
amazing sound system and a stage
all the staging and the lights and sound
so we do all those basics all the
important stuff i don't have anything
fancy like a catwalk or any of that crap
um but uh we have two semis and
then my tour bus and the crew tour bus
and a crew of 12.
um but that was a merchandise truck i
have crap i sell crap
dude that we love that man
we love selling crap we talk to people
all the time
who just seem to be doing so much better
at us
there's so much better than us than we
are doing the same things
uh yeah like everybody you got a whole
semi truck just for merch
no that's a that's a uh what do you call
it a panel truck so it's
yeah it's big but it's not a semi okay
but you're doing like six to nine
thousand people we're doing like
three to six hundred you know right now
we'll probably be doing better because
we got upgraded to theaters
right we just doing theaters if you're
doing theaters yeah and
so your per head number is the big deal
you know i don't know what we do for
head i think it's like
i can't remember it just oh my god it's
been so long i'm forgetting all this
stuff but yeah
i bet you can do really well on the
perhaps what do you guys sell do you
sell
bobble heads and how'd you ask
sunglasses socks glasses socks hats
hoodies dick pic pens hot sauce
you know that you know those pens hot
sauce
yeah you can get it on amazon hot sauce
for your butthole it's called steamboats
hot sauce for your butthole and it is
available on amazon yeah
and where did you find the hot sauce
company how did that happen we uh
they were it was one of these private
label companies
and they had the craziest array of
different sauces for us to try
and um yeah we tried to and i liked
this one kind and i like this other kind
and i was
actually able to combine them so
technically i created a completely
unique and original hot sauce
that uh which is available on amazon
which is available on amazon it's also
available at stevo.com
i'm go i'm going so it's called the
steve all i do all i got to enter is
stevo and hot sauce right and i'll find
out yeah exactly
have your people reach out to me i'll
send you a case i'll send you a gallon
of hot sauce for your butthole yeah we
sell about a gallon
i can't wait oh that's great i love
hearing stuff like that because i
i was at a i was eating at a fancy steak
restaurant once i was going through the
wine
thing and it said dunham sellers
and i'm like dunham sellers that wow i
don't know if i'm related but i doubt it
so i ended up contacting them and i said
and they were apparently fans
and so we ended up they were they the
same thing they sent me a bunch of
different wines and i was able to pick
three of different ones and um so we had
it on my website for a long time but it
was genius what they did
is they took their regular bottle of
wine but when somebody would call them
from my website and want you know the
achmed
syrah or whatever it was they would take
the wine
and they had another sticker made that
looked exactly like their label
but it was ahmed done in the same paper
and the same everything
foil and so they stuck it on there and
it looked like they we'd done a
completely customized wine
just for me and it was just [ __ ]
because it was just their wine with
one little sticker of mine on it it's
smart
they sold it for a long time and then i
don't know what happened i i don't know
if they're
uh democratic and i lean right or
whatever but i must have told a joke or
something because that that relationship
ended and i don't know what i did wrong
ah
they probably made some [ __ ] you money
off that and just quit
yeah i don't know either that or not i
you know come to think of it i don't
think many of my fans drink wine so
maybe that was the problem all mine are
beer stevia when you go to a comedy club
do you know what food and beverage they
stock up on when you go
i know that as a sober guy i've been
sober for
12 years yet my audience
at the comedy clubs just drinks more
alcohol
than anybody who ever goes through those
comedy clubs i have the most
alcoholic thirsty audience
well mine was beer they always had to
stock up on beer bottle beer for some
reason budweiser
yeah yeah yeah probably who not coors
for lone star for god's sake
yeah i mean hey i i believe it man so so
now
all the stuff that you sell like when
you're not on the road
like when uh it's just online can we
plug your website where people buy your
merch online
yeah it's jeffdunham.com and uh uh we're
getting ready to open an amazon store i
have a few things on amazon but uh we're
gonna
open amazon store but yeah jeffdom.com i
don't know i have
man this stuff that we've come up with
uh has been great and i love
do i have anything in here no i got
bobble heads and
none of my stuff's in here it's all toys
um
uh but we have bobble heads we have
talking
animatronic dummies uh dolls of my
characters
we have actual full-size controller quiz
dummies of my characters oh wow but we
have
the t-shirts and the you know all the
typical stuff and they just did a uh
funko pop um just like they did with
gabe
and those went real well uh and i i made
the mistake
of saying okay guys we're going to sell
the autographed ones but not
let's not put a limit on them yeah
you know how long it takes to sign 10
000 funko pops
i just did 12 000 signed prints for
charity with tony hawk
you're [ __ ] too
that's a lot and and and that's it we we
sell all this stuff
all the time and then when we do the one
damn thing for charity
that's when we go gangbusters
like you didn't get a piece of it not a
penny i made an actual
point of a 100 of the proceeds go to
charity
and we're sitting there watching doing
all the work to fulfill
i'm still working on it 12 000 orders
it's just like wow that was the hit
and what was it what was the thing it
was uh i got together with tony hawk
the legendary skateboarder and we pushed
two ramps up against a wall so that we
could comment you know a good clip
and you ride up the ramp and then you're
doing this sort of a large wall ride
and he went off a bigger ramp than i did
so it's kind of
as a double rainbow we're both both
riding on the wall together and then we
came down on uh
on a ramp and and successfully pulled it
off it's a pretty impressive photo
and we both we both signed uh the you
know
12 000 prints it's so funny i've had a
couple people reach out to me on the
website
and they're like hey you guys sent me
the wrong product this isn't what i
ordered and i'm like
can you send me what we've sent you and
it's the same
picture but it's sideways and i'm like
turn it upright and they're like oh [ __ ]
i'm an idiot
i've had that like four times happening
with that print dude
yeah i don't know man but uh okay so
when when people go to jeffdonham.com
they
they order uh how much is a full-size
ventriloquist dummy
i don't know when i say full size you
know it's like full-size
like kid size it's like 40 inches tall
something like that
we were selling them for 100 bucks we
got ahmed the dead terrorist he's for a
hundred bucks but it's good because it's
got the mechanism
and the whole deal with the head on the
street sure that sounds like a great
deal
and uh and how does that order get
fulfilled
is it uh we have a warehouse and got a
couple people working in there when i go
on tour
you know they it's all hell for them
because they're packing pallets and
shipping out pallets and all that
so now it's been kind of a down time for
them but as a husband and wife and they
run the warehouse and every once while
we have temp uh people come over when
uh orders get heavy but they're in that
warehouse and there's you know
piles of crap and you know it's really
interesting to me
when something goes out of fashion or
something we don't sell because you know
you're always going to have
x number of those things and so i i like
going in there and just going through
the crap that i forgot about every once
will give that stuff to either the
military or the charity
or whatever because it's shirts and you
know uh
i can't remember somebody sent me a
picture one time
of some poor kid in like east africa or
something like that
and he had on one of my shirts that's
funny yeah that's great
i don't know if i should feel good about
that or bad about that you know
so it's so cool to hear you say that
because
we just like uh it's
a a couple weeks ago or three weeks ago
maybe we got the keys
to our first warehouse where we're like
we're renting a warehouse and
we're we're actually the ones fulfilling
our own orders
because this third party fulfillment
center that we were using
i mean we were one of 3 600 clients
there and it just like
just we just felt lost in the shuffle
and we decided you know what
we can do better by our people if we uh
do it ourselves
yeah nobody loves you more than you and
so
the you know like uh eleanor uh
roosevelt eleanor roosevelt yeah now it
said if you're gonna do something right
do it yourself so
um uh that's the way we we did the same
thing we had a third party
fulfillment company and they were you
know i just i never felt like it was
done right and i knew they were getting
too much money and we thought so
same exactly what you did we thought
nope we're gonna get a warehouse we're
gonna hire some people
and make it a family quote family thing
make it all in-house
and it's been great the only trouble is
i gotta give bigger bonuses at christmas
it's a good problem to have yeah yeah
it's nice too because like i'm really
impatient
and especially in business and if we're
paying money i want it now and like
now that we have our own fulfillment
house it's like if i want something done
it gets done immediately versus sending
an email getting a response back
then three days late it's like it's too
late so now
now that we're in control it's it's
fantastic i made the mistake
of looking at the dummy uh behind you
and it keeps staring at me and now i'm
kind of freaking out
is it this over here yeah yeah see those
are those are old
those are really old dummies and that
were made during the depression
i wasn't even ready for how interesting
the story about those dolls was gonna be
but you know how i said i'm a healthier
guy these days
let me tell you i've been getting laid a
lot
i've been getting laid really good and
check out my little chunk of puss over
here
yeah honey let me say getting laid yep
and you know what else i'm doing in a
real healthy way
pooping here's a news flash for you
yeah news flash the human body was not
designed to poop sitting down on a
toilet
now the human body is designed to be
standing up and squatting like that
that's why i use squatty potty come on
check this out i mean you sit on the
toilet
right there this squatty potty stool
elevates your legs puts you in that
healthy squatting position
for a complete total
evacuation and by evacuation mean get
all that sloppy poop out poop
completely yeah we got squatty potty on
every
single toilet and i i won't just won't
poop without it
i hate having to improvise if i'm on the
road
it's like give me a trash can or
something no no a microwave in the hotel
room
yeah and i'm serious about this squatty
potty's important to me
and i want you to try it so you're going
to go to squattypotty.com
stevo and you get 20 off your order
telling you guys if you're not using
squatty potty
you're not pooping healthy and that
needs to change
so one more time you're gonna go to
squattypotty.com
stevo you get 20 off your order
and you're gonna thank me for it
now let's hear about those dolls the
little tiny
one there with the orange hair that's
called mortimer's nerd he's a little
plastic one
that i got that's my first dummy i got
when i was in the third grade but these
other two
as where well as those guys up there
those were all built
during the depression by two brothers
with zero uh education on how to do it
and they became like the porsche
of controllers wow i love that i'll show
you real quick hold on let me see i
think i can get it oh man you know i was
gonna feel like a jerk
asking you to hold up a dummy
for the thumbnail
it looks like i'm going to get it anyway
right you got to believe that the jeff
dunham thumbnail for the podcast
performs better if he's holding a dummy
don't use this one this is not one of my
characters this is one that okay
like years ago but let me show this is a
typical ventriloquist dummy but not you
know what i mean
what i love about my characters is that
they're not they're not the typical
ventriloquist dummy
but what's amazing about this guy is all
the stuff that he does is this dude
there's the mouth there's the upper lip
let me give him a little closer here
i really felt badly for the people who
are listening only
on the audio only version
well i'll describe it so there's the
mouth moves the upper lip moves the
eyebrows moving
his eyes go side to side and up and down
and that's from the porsche
hair his hair goes up he goes cross-eyed
let's cross oh that's his nose he says
sniff like that
his ears go out oh uh he looks here like
this
i think that doesn't his nose lights up
you can barely see that
so it's like you know but this thing is
complicated
i feel like i'd want a separate hotel
room on my rider for that guy because if
i woke up in the middle of night to piss
and he was looking at me
i wouldn't be able to sleep anymore but
let me show you just from a technical
thing just again
you're right i don't want to bore the
people that are only listening but this
is how complicated these
things are so back here you see all
these levers and
and keys but that's not what a typical
dummy is like year was that made
huh what years was that made 1937. it's
like morse code wow
yep yep and this thing is probably worth
about 25 30 grand
oh my gosh that's all i can totally
believe that that was worth more
oh it's a piece of americana it's a
piece of artwork it's uh
you know it's amazing so i might i'm
joking if i ask you to hold up one of
your characters
yeah i'll show you my new guy that i
created i created him during the
pandemic
and
that would ruin everything right yeah
exactly
but nobody's mouth is moving please
don't tell that joke you know how many
people have sent me memes and jokes like
hey
your job's really easy now you can wear
a bed yeah yeah
so um but this guy i created online and
we did a series of youtube videos
uh as i created him all the way from you
know sculpting the head
all the way through the 3d scanning and
the 3d printing
and um yeah that's what it said in your
documentary that you're
so involved in actually making these
characters building these puppets
yourself
yeah yeah i do it all myself but let me
show you this guy so this guy
we all have our internet trolls and so
he's an internet troll
and we had a we had a naming contest
online
and some guy came up with this name and
i thought it was great but we named him
earl
but it's spelled url
where did the name dummy come from like
why did they call it a dummy
is that is there any that's a google
question i have no idea i should know
the answer
dummy like it said dummy like it's
something that's uh fake i don't know
i feel like you hurt their feelings this
is earl
and uh what's up earl this is the uh the
genius part of him that i like
it's like this
that's cool and uh yeah like uh for sure
i get to talk to like stevo
that's like my favorite thing ever
yeah he's not gonna say anything mean
about me
no yeah
so anyway i have never used him in a
show
and i was gonna use him on the special
that's on tomorrow at eight o'clock
pacific in
eastern um um uh i did i was gonna use
him on the show but
it takes a long time to develop the
character and to really figure out who
he is because i gotta get to know him
because i i pride myself on being more
of a hopefully a comedy writer
because if i come up with one setup one
question
if i'm a good comedy writer every one of
those characters will have a different
answer for it
so i haven't gotten to know that guy
well there's two characters in my career
that did not work out and it's because i
could not think like them
ahmed the dead terrorist i i understand
that guy we all get that mad every once
in a while
we don't really kill people but we you
know you envision it maybe now and then
um there's bubba j the the redneck guy i
grew up in texas i get that
there's peanut my little wild and crazy
purple guy there's walter my
curmudgeonly old man
all those things i get but when i
created the female character
for a movie called dinner for schmucks
um we had all that we got all the rights
remember
me be able to use her in my act after
the movie
i i could not think like a woman i could
not i couldn't write jokes i didn't get
it
i had other female comics help me write
jokes but it was like
a pain in the ass because i had no
earthly idea what to say
in any given situation you know what i'm
saying it wasn't legit
and then the other one and this was way
back when
uh i was trying to make fun of prejudice
so i came up with sweet daddy d
my black my african-american
african-american character the black
character
and he was basically my my my manager
and he was a pimp
and i had a bunch of black writers like
three guys
uh comics i mean help me write jokes for
him because i'm like i know you guys sit
around and tell
jokes about white people so just tell me
what those jokes are you're not going to
offend me because i want to know what
those white jokes are i want to make fun
of myself in my race i want to try and
turn it around somehow
and that ca and it came off okay i
actually used him in a special on comedy
center when it came off all right
but it was the same thing when i would
sit there and try and add lube with him
in an interview
or try and uh write jokes for him it was
completely fake because i had no earthly
idea i can't put myself in the
african-americans shoes i have no idea
what they lived through so i couldn't
it just was not it didn't work didn't
work how much like
with the achmed the dead terrorist
like that when did that character
begin when did you first create that
character well it was a year after 9 11
and um we hadn't found osama bin laden
nobody knew where he was nobody know
what
had known what happened to him uh nobody
knew
and i looked to leno and letterman at
the time
and there's nothing funny about 9 11
never will be i think even 100 years you
know titanic jokes now are still kind of
so you know too many people died so
with 9 11 you're not going to make fun
of that but leno and letterman were
making fun of those guys osama bin laden
those guys who did the deed
so i thought nobody knows where osama is
but i know where he is
he's half dead and he's hiding out and
living in a suitcase with my characters
and so i was at a store called oz here
in los angeles
and they had this bumbling plastic
skeleton and usually what i do when i
build a character i try it out i i have
a little cheapy version of them first
and i try them out on stage and write
the jokes if it works then i'll build
the real
character and i thought all right i'm
going to make this bumbling stupid idiot
uh uh skeleton and call him ahmed
i mean call him the dead osama and so i
made this
bumbling skeleton out of this halloween
decoration put a little turban on his
head
and i thought i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna chicken out and try and do this
someplace far away
from ground zero uh i sat down and i
wrote jokes
pretending imagining that there were
relatives
of people who had died in 9 11
that they were sitting in that audience
what were they a year later ready to
hear
what could they joke about what could
help them move forward and what would be
okay
so i wrote that material and i went to
a club called bananas uh there was a few
bananas but it was six miles from ground
zero
and i was pretty big in the comedy clubs
back then it was sold out the first show
was a friday night
sold out friday night and uh i did my
first 45 minutes and everything was
great they all loved me so i was
sold and then i said to them you know
there's one sentence we've all been
waiting to hear
and that is osama bin laden is dead the
roof came off the place
and i said well i got a surprise for you
he's here with us this evening ladies
and gentlemen osama bin laden
and it was like god took a vacuum and
sucked out of the all the air out of
that comedy club
and i know they were thinking what has
this [ __ ] from california
decided to show us right now and i
pulled this stupid bumbling skeleton out
of the suitcase and started going
through the jokes
and it was like it couldn't have gone
any better and that's when i came up
with the ikea thing
and uh it was it was freaking awesome
and then i kept doing it
year after year after year for about i
guess like three three years maybe not
too long but three years
and then everybody kind of forgot about
osama bin laden and i took him out of
the act
and then come 2007 my second comedy
special comes along
and i thought i'd better put two new
characters in besides my old ones
and i thought you know that old dead
osama worked but i always like to keep
my specials evergreen so if you look at
it ten years later it's still funny
and you're not like you know making
richard nixon jokes
so um i i i i thought
i'm gonna change it from osama bin laden
and instead of offending one person i'm
gonna offend an
entire group of dangerous people and so
i called him ahmed the dead terrorist we
didn't say where he was from
we didn't say where the accent was uh
there's even a point
and didn't say he was muslim he would
make a point of saying he's not muslim i
didn't want to people what people make
and think i was making
fun of their religion um
and uh uh so brought him back
and uh and then created that iteration
of the current iteration of him
and uh uh started doing that and it went
over great and the special and then
we came out with a song called uh jingle
bombs
which went bananas on youtube and it
went worldwide
and that's when i started getting
credible death threats
and uh but it was off to the races after
that so it was because of ahmed and
jingle bombs and comedy central and that
special
that kind of put me where i am now who
were the death threats coming from
uh
the incredible ones where we got the fbi
involved uh my
ex-wife no i'm kidding uh
they were from the other side of the
world we don't really know but i tell
you there's the negative and there's the
positive
because um so many people embraced that
i was getting letters from the military
from all over the world i was getting
letters from all
from parents of guys and women in the
military uh
there were we started selling little
dolls of ahmed
i was sent pictures of ahmed sitting up
in the window of helicopter
military helicopters they would make it
artwork on the nose of the aircraft
um it was it was unbelievable and and i
also heard
that uh on good authority that there
were businessmen in iraq
sitting around at lunch going i kill you
and laughing so
that's fine man oh and when i went to
did a show in abu dhabi
i thought oh my this is terrifying and
uh uh
all the front row was all the guys in
the dish dash and the
the muslim outfits and all that stuff
and all the women were a few rows back
and and of course ahmed was your hero
but then
two nights later i'm in the middle of
tel aviv israel for two thousand jewish
people and guess who their favorite
character was
the dead i figured out the difference
though the muslims love him because they
think he's one of them the jews love him
because he's dead
okay wow man that's crazy it just
i get the sense that uh
that you've got diplomatic immunity i
remember i'll never forget one time
i uh you know became i became friendly
with uh
some some gangster rappers you know
like known as the g unit are they you
know and uh
and i went into their studio this was so
long ago but i went into their
their mixtape studio and i was like oh
you know
who are you guys beefing with you know
like who's the fear
and they would like mention someone i
would like they'd give me a name or be
like oh that guy like i'll kill that guy
like i was you know
i'm on a hot mic and i'm just trying to
like you know
engage in like really scary you know and
then and then i met
dave chappelle so like shortly after
that i said i said dave
dude i think i might get killed by a
rapper
i think because i was in the studio
talking all this trash
on all these like really legitimately
scary gangster
rappers and he said oh come on steve he
says you're stevo
you got diplomatic immunity
whatever you know again we have parallel
parallel uh things going on because
my thought has always been do you really
want to be the terrorist who kills the
puppet guy
that's true and i thought very very much
exactly the same thing there's nothing
tough about picking on stevo
yeah i think we could do we could do a
tour together of offending people and no
one would care
right i think we see very much eye to
eye on that and uh
and and where like when in in the
beginning i told you how much i related
to
to you know this kind of kind of a a
fresh
take an original approach to comedy and
nobody wants to try the new thing
you know ah well the thing is i think my
problem is that it's an old and tired
art
and art form and uh you know everybody
makes fun of the prop guys they make fun
of the the jugglers and the
ventriloquists and the variety acts
um and ventriloquism is even worse
because even in vaudeville days
we weren't the main act we were the guys
that were shoved out on stage
while they closed the curtain and reset
the show for the real variety act so we
were just between
and it wasn't until a guy named edgar
bergen came along in the 30s and
uh had a number one radio show uh for 10
years
um he was like the seinfeld of the radio
era that that it became a mainstay
but look i know what i do and i get it
and it's it's lame even i look at my own
my own publicity shots and go really
there's a grown man sitting there with
five dolls
and he pretends he's talking to them and
people buy it
it's just is this really this is why i
think that we live in a in a uh
a simulation because the fact that i'm
selling out arenas
with the dummies is like there's there's
a man there's a there's a guy
and a son playing a video game somewhere
and the sun says to the dad let's make a
ventriloquist really famous and sell out
giant venues
and the dad goes you're nuts but yeah
that sounds fun let's try that
right i mean dude i i saw it on the news
that that uh
like the highest level of scientists uh
like suggested that there's that we
really might be actually living
in in some kind of a man-made computer
simulation and then that's what we're
actually living in
and i mean there's a lot of stuff to
point to to make it seem like okay
what the [ __ ] that's weird exhibit a
jeff dunham
right and you know what you just said
too about the
the ventriloquist they were the guys
that got shoved out while you know they
put the curtain to reset
i don't know if you know this but my
first uh profession
was circus clown i was uh oh no
wow oh i remember somebody saying that a
long time ago i was i was a circus clown
and a graduate of ringling brothers and
barnum bailey clown
college and when i worked in the circus
it was a 100
so that they could be setting up and
breaking down the trampoline i got to be
like hey
look over here don't look at what
they're setting up and breaking down
over there
wow you guys are alike dude and how long
did you do that
ah i did it for i i didn't get a
contract with ringling brothers
after graduating clown college which is
pretty sad because there was like
it wasn't a high-paying job and uh
and then i did get a contract for for
royal caribbean cruise lines i was a
clown on cruise ships for six months
got fired from that and then i went to
work at uh
the flea market circus where were uh
distracted from the trampolines
hang on you skipped the best part how do
you get fired off a cruise ship
what it was was that uh i was part of a
of a clown troop they were the boss
clowns and then they were they were
trying to
sort of like add new tears so that i
worked in a group of four clowns i was
one of four
and we worked underneath the boss clowns
um
and you know we were supposed to be
writing material and doing there as well
as like going around the ship and
entertaining people and we would perform
in the theater over
in the theater at night to open up for
the big vegas style
show and it was just that i had like a
whole bunch of cool bar tricks up my
sleeve i had all these like little
things i do
i had this idea of what i thought was
rad and i didn't
really care for the type of comedy the
other clowns i worked with
were trying to write i was just like i
don't think that's funny
i think that sucks i don't think you
guys like are really
rad with your skills they'd be like
working on their little
little bits and i just had my earphones
in and i'd be practicing my juggling you
know like
i just went i was disrespectful of them
and i felt like i didn't have to worry
about it because
when it came time to entertain people i
really had the goods like you know i
didn't
but what happened was all three of the
other clowns went to the cruise ship
brass
not even just the boss clowns but the
brass of the cruise ship
and they said look if stevo comes back
for another contract
we all quit it was a clown mutiny
wow oh well i know but had i
not been fired from that job uh
i would have missed out on the the the
jackass pilot
because because they got me off that
ship just in the nick of time
to go shoot for the jackass pilot and
and uh had that not been the case i
would have been juggling oranges in the
middle of the damn
caribbean ocean on a stupid cruise ship
and i never would have
and you wouldn't have the rv and uh
wendy from peru paul and uh yeah we're
windy from peru
right and uh and it was i went out and
shopped for the pilot for jackass
and once that was in the can i came back
and i got the job at the flea market
circus
i worked there for another i wouldn't do
the flea market circus this was in fort
lauderdale florida
it was the uh the the the largest
flea market swap meet and actually the
record they hold is the largest drive-in
movie theater with 14
screens i believe drive-in movie theater
at
the flea market plus it's an amusement
park and they had a circus
like a full on like one ring circus with
three elephants and a tiger which really
upset me
and uh i was i told i showed up i said
hey man i'm a clown i'm a graduate of
clown college they said you start
tomorrow
in an actual show you know like uh they
just show up
and all right get out there show us what
you got and you're here here we're at
the flea market
they they liked everything that i did i
had
different gags that um that i stole from
the circus
i had some stuff that was um you know
unique to me i would do a
skateboard act of fire breathing
acrobatics act a balancing act
imagine this guy comes in for an
interview
all right jeff i made a lot of kids cry
did you quit or did you get fired ah
that when i got fired because i
i got fired for every job i ever had
they uh like when i got the call
that that the jackass pilot was ordered
to series
and they said that they're going to come
out to florida to film me for the first
season of the series
i went and told the circus owners like
hey guys i'm going to be famous it's
going to be great and mtv's gonna come
they're gonna film this show
and uh just on the exact day i said that
would happen knoxville showed up at the
circus with the camera crew
and the circus owner comes to me says
what are these [ __ ] doing here
filming my elephants i said it's mtv and
they're not i told you they were coming
they're not gonna like do anything and
and get themselves in trouble like
says uh he just gave me this grumpy
little whole thing and that just like i
told my word i went off and filmed for
five days
came back bandaged up having been bitten
by a shark all
beaten up and hung over and showed up
back for work and all right i'm back
they said we don't have don't have it in
the budget to keep you around anymore
wow you're like but i'm six dollars an
hour
you don't even pay me you pay me beer
i made 500 bucks a week and i was always
uh owing the drug dealer
i always had to go to the drug dealer
when i got it
500 a week is pretty good for back then
huh
and they gave me in cash and then all of
a sudden i got like the tax form w9 i
was like what
what so tell me all that that's all in
the book right
yeah yeah that's 100 in my book plus
every copy at stevo.com is personally
autographed hands
by hand i autograph every copy and you
can get yourself and it's a new york
times bestseller plus it's got a
average customer rating on amazon five
stars and your signature looks like a
dick
and my signature looks just like a penis
it's a dick a graph
that's nice
he's like man we had some stuff in
common
i was gonna have you meet my kids but
yeah my signature looks like a vagina
oh there you go there you go that's
great
yeah all right man that's great dude so
how long is this special that that comes
out tomorrow
well uh it's uh you know typical 44
minutes uh it's an
hour special but you know once you get
through with sure commercial breaks
yeah and we you know uh my live show is
usually two hours
and this thing i i had again i had no
earthly idea how long anything was and
i'm like
how can i time this with only a hundred
people because
with the bigger ones you time you know
my timing is different because the last
would be longer and i knew the lefts are
going to be much shorter with
100 people in there so you know i wrote
and wrote and wrote and wrote and wrote
and wrote and
uh came up with you know it's nobody
cares
but two hours of me talking is about 10
000 words
wow yeah and so this special was about
000 words and i ended up doing an hour
and 20 minutes
so obviously the laughs were much
shorter but then we edited it down to
that and we're just we're in the final
edit like when i
have finished with you guys i know today
is the day after
it's on now
we gotta finish in two hours so you
still are you're gonna deliver it right
at the wire
exactly we're gonna deliver like and
like when we uh we get finished right
now
no but it's it's a week out if you want
to talk in real numbers so what is today
today is
sunday sunday today sunday so we deliver
it i think
tonight or tomorrow and it's it was
when i came up with that this idea was
two months ago so
i've never done anything this fast yeah
are you stressed out
i think i'm more stressed out about the
airing than i was the performance
because i
you know one of these things after
you've edited it and gone back over and
watched it 20 times it's not funny
anymore
you know right in every single special
i've ever done this is the tenth one i
sit back and i go
i don't know if this is funny and
everybody around me and my wife goes no
trust says it's funny it's good don't
worry about it but
i i don't i yeah no i think it's funny
it made me laugh the first couple times
i saw it so uh
yeah how many shows did you do i mean i
would typically you do
uh tape the special a couple times so
that you can
we always do two and uh we ended up
using most of
one show i think that's how it normally
goes
yeah yeah because for me it literally
was the very first night was
you know it was the first time i'd ever
done the jokes so we went in and you
know noodled a few jokes and that
had a few punch-ups and so the second
night i had you know maybe ten percent
more jokes and better jokes and
so we most of that so i think that
it's gonna it's gonna do great i think
that uh when when i first heard oh
jeff's got a new special coming out i i
my initial reaction was man god how
how far in advance have all these
networks and
streaming platforms been banking these
you know like it's getting
i felt like it's getting to the point
where it's almost uncomfortable
to put out a new special with like a
full packed audience because it's so
evident that it's
so old but really nice to hear that that
you've done
this just three weeks ago with like the
full kind of
it's current you know it's current and i
think there's going to be a real
curiosity as to what it looks like for
jeff dunham the arena guy
to film in front of 100 people outdoors
in malibu
right and the taste for a long time with
comedy special was to not you know in
the early days of these comedy specials
you always got the audience shots
and you could use them for editing and
then they said no we don't want the
audience shots anymore so there were a
couple specials i did well
you didn't see the audience at all and
watch a lot of comedy specials now they
never do crowd shots
and i said no we have to show the crowd
on this to show everybody in masks to
show what we're in the middle of
it's got to be and it was as you know i
tried to make it as down home and
charming as possible it's outside
um you know and so i
you know and i think it worked out and
um you know nobody
uh nobody i don't think anybody expected
it to do as
well for it to go as well as it did so
uh and also
it's the first time in a long time i've
done something that's pg and not pg-13
or r
there's a you know there was only two
f-bombs in there and those were bleeped
of course for comedy central but those
were ad-libs when i was messing with the
crowd
otherwise it's completely
family-friendly the subject matter is
okay
and i wanted to do that because of what
you just said stevo everybody's sitting
around
uh it's i think it's the perfect time
uh for families to get together and be
able to watch something because you know
you know what's doing the big numbers on
tv right now are the freaking disney
sing-alongs
you want to shoot yourself in the head
but that's what everybody's watching
you know that's what people love and so
i thought i can come up with something
that grandma and the kids can sit down
and watch together and not have to
explain too much
yeah well that's great man that's super
good and i'm glad that we were able to
pull this together thank you for uh
jumping on this with such short notice i
know i appreciate you guys uh
having me on and uh it's a pleasure i i
mean i i
you know somebody like you i really
respect you
you're nudge dude and i love it it's a
congratulations
yeah i appreciate that a lot man it's a
high honor and i really do
feel that uh that i i relate to you in
in
multiple ways you know i think that uh
we're kindred spirits and and i'm a fan
and it's been a real honor to have you
on well that's a compliment i i
appreciate it same here and i look
forward to coming to see the rv sometime
you come see my airstream
yeah that's cool yeah we're about to hit
up that uh malibu beach rv park even
though
i don't know if i want to go
uh we'll find some other places let me
check county line yeah do you ever surf
no i am the least athletic guy on the
frickin planet
i i gotta you know i just no man
i'm like no no no
there's a reason in junior high in high
school that for my side job i became a
dj you know why
because i couldn't dance and i didn't
want to dance so i just spun the damn
records
great i love it man well yeah i would
say it'd be great to get together with
our recreational vehicles and have a
good old time man
and celebrate the smashing success of
your new special what's the title of it
oh the name of the special i i i would
lay at night and try and memorize it but
i never got it down it's jeff dunham's
completely unrehearsed last minute
pandemic
brilliant holiday special wow sums it up
right there
yeah yeah i came up with that title and
i and everybody laughed and i said
let's ask comedy central what they think
and you know as a joke and they came
back and said we love it
wow yeah great super cool man i think
that that
you've got enough of a body of work that
people can trust you that
it's going to be great man i can't wait
to see it i appreciate it
cool man right on brother stevo scott
paul and wendy thanks for the time you
guys
is that guy just plain cool or what man
i'm telling you really fell in love with
jeff
dunham and i hope you did too if you did
go ahead and let him know
man just post something on instagram tag
them just let them know that that was
super cool
you know what you're super cool too man
i always appreciate the people who stick
around to the very end
and uh yeah i just need you to know that
i love you
and thank you hope you're having a good
thanksgiving
yeah dude